people are going wild for Disney's new
animal based animated feature Zootopia
I'm Dave and welcome to your animal
friendly GS news update Disney's latest
animated films utopia is a record
breaker the movie opened on Friday and
made more than 70 3.7 million dollars
domestically over the weekend according
to varieties box office report it beat
frozen which made 60 7.4 million during
its opening weekend in 2013 no the
Zootopia set a new opening-weekend
record for a disney animation film but
not a Pixar picture Zootopia is however
now the fourth biggest US March release
ever variety explains as utopia is set
to continue to do well as there are no
other major family-oriented movies
coming out until the jungle book another
Disney movie in mid-april there is an
absence of competition Disney's Dave
Hollis said we are set up to have a big
big run Zootopia has been out for three
weeks already internationally it made
another 60 3.4 million overseas this
week boosting its total global hall to
230 2.5 million dollars Disney has not
divulged a budget for the film before
itís States it's likely north of 100
million so it's sensible to think we're
in for a Zootopia to have you seen
Disney's new animal adventure if so we'd
love to hear your opinions in the
comment section below and for all your
gaming and entertainment news keep it
gamespot com
you